i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
it's a very serious business you have
lives especially this one
and your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah we jumped the [ __ ] out of them oh
no hold on look at it
look at this aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner's
permit
jeez
that was good pull it off 100 miles an
hour to go three feet what the hell
would you do that for don't be that guy
in traffic the guy that pulls out 100
miles an hour and then goes three miles
an hour in front of everybody
all right i'm comfortable right now i
got my nice
honeydew fleece hoodie on actually it
feels like fleece on the inside soft
cotton really it's not fleece
i got my nape pants on
you got knight pants you like them
hey you're so comfortable go right on
people here i can do this whole series
on fights i've been in so many damn
fights i've been in bar fights i've been
jumped
multiple times watching a guy crossing
the dogs here
just keep looking in case some [ __ ]
pulls out of nowhere
[Music]
you know what preakness is no so
preakness
is a horse race it's the second leg of
the triple crown and they pack a hundred
thousand people on the infield of a
horse track and i mean people are on
acid shrooms you get there at 8am and
you just drink all day the actual
there's races going all day long but the
main one isn't until like round
end of the day maybe 4 30 5 o'clock and
they sell shirts that say horses there
were horses here like you people get
it's just a waste fish the waste fest
you got a green light here
that means go even your sister knows
that the one year we all we rented two
school buses we had that many people
going together and we all get down there
and it's like 8 a.m we're already
drinking on the bus like they don't they
can't stop we're just drinking drinking
drinking they know what's going on i'm
there
both my brothers and two of my cousins
timmy and gary all of us are together
and a bunch of our friends were all
there we drink all day and we get done
and we're in the parking lot we're on
our bus while everyone's still waiting
you know you're waiting for these idiots
who are just shit-faced don't even know
where they are anymore some people might
not make it you're stopping at a green
light
it i thought it was yellow
i thought it was yellow
i'm sorry
anyway we get we're on the bus number
one and there's a bus sitting right next
to us this is the lot of school buses
we're on rented school buses this bus
next to us is full of it looks like
friends i mean they're all talking to
each other and everything they're
friendly whatever but it's packed and
you just see this one guy and girl at
the the doors are open you know yeah and
he's up pointing up and yelling and
yelling and yelling
and they were like let them come up on
the bus let them come up and the guy and
the girl go up on the bus and they let
them both of them walk all the way back
and then there's some words exchanged
and
as if it was like coordinated
like it was an organism they all at the
same time jumped and they beat the [ __ ]
out of this dude i mean
so bad they beat his ass threw him off
the bus on the gravel threw her off
right behind him i was like holy [ __ ] we
getting pulled over
they look over at us they start spitting
in our windows we're putting a win it's
hot we're putting the windows up they're
spitting and i'm like don't fight back
don't fight back they just beat their
friends up don't fight back
but this one dude on our bus had to
[ __ ] be you know wasted thinking he
was gonna go over there and make a
difference i was like they just beat
their friends up they're gonna kill you
dude they're gonna kill you and i never
really liked this dude and he never
really liked me
um so i was like you know what go over
and see what they want so
he went over and he got on the bus and i
was like oh my god
and same thing
they let them walk all the way back to
the back of the bus and i was like he's
[ __ ] dead and then same thing boom
pounce on him and i mean they're killing
him but now
they see him from our bus so everybody
on that bus decides they're going to get
off and they're going to kick our ass
and attack our bus they start getting
out they bash our windows out this bus
driver this poor lady screaming up front
like oh my god
she's like y'all ain't getting the
security deposit that's the first thing
you've seen
we're not getting our security deposit
back they're bashing the windows and
spits she's like jesus christ she starts
to bust up there is nowhere near the
right amount of people that are supposed
to be back on this bus to leave yeah and
she didn't give a [ __ ] she's like
she screams on the you know
walkie-talkie trying to call other buses
and [ __ ]
now in between us
this dude's getting killed he's getting
killed so i got off the back of the bus
i opened up the emergency exit and i
went i mean and i'm telling you in
between these two buses is it in eight
feet yeah and make a left on lincoln and
there's
maybe 40 people in there and i mean just
throwing haymakers just back you know
just punching trying to survive
and
i go right into the middle of it and i
duck down and i grab this dude he's
shirtless and he's in a pair of khaki
shorts and i grabbed him by the wrist
i drug him across the gravel drug him
all the way back i got him on the
[ __ ] bus his nose was pushed i swear
over here on the side it looked like
when hello di nada hit ben
roethlisberger on that football game
when he pushed his nose to the side that
[ __ ] was over on the side he's all cut
up i mean he looked like he had bite
marks on him and [ __ ] like they were
killing them on that bus
but now
you know you're in baltimore and when
drunk people see a fight they're just
they're happy yeah and now all these
strangers are in there and i mean people
are going and finally i see my cousin
gary and he's just in the middle and
he's just looking around he's just
popping he's just he's born and raised
in baltimore city he's just deaf he
can't hear anything so if anybody's
coming he doesn't know if you're a
friend or a foe but he's deaf and he's
just he's just out there popping back
back i'm going gary i'm up in the bus
when i'm going gary yeah i'm grabbing
his hair from the top he's swinging up
like it's getting on the bus really this
lady
she's plowing through the cops come in
they're pepper spraying everybody come
on we can't get arrested we get him on
the bus now our five are accounted for
everybody else hey good luck to you
they're out there beating and killing
each other cops are coming in bang and
spraying spraying spray it was amazing
he's like
oh dude
there were maybe 15 or 20 people on the
bus
she took us back to the park right the
a school bus a yellow school bus man
just beat this [ __ ] the windows
shattered out no man there's some but
the most of them are gone the the sides
all keyed up and scratched and kicked
the b i mean this side looked like it
had been the i could see that this side
over here looked like it stayed it went
to canada that's what it looked like
just imagine seeing that bus just just
driving back to wherever you get dropped
off and just someone just seeing that
but oh man people getting out bloody and
beat up like they were like where were
they like y'all went to preakness that's
what it looked like
yeah
i might have been the same people i
think it was
[Music]
[Music]
you